Before creation itself
There were six singularities then the universe exploded into existence
And the remnants of these systems were forged into concentrated
ingots
Infinity stones
For my universe back
We were unstoppable I
Was his weapon the conquest that built Asgard's Empire one by one of realms became ours
But then simply because my ambition outgrew his he banished me
Their King fells
I'm with you to the end of the line pal you just don't wanna give up doing this all day
I feel
So from all of us at Stark Industries I would like to personally
Tony what are you doing back there what is that put it back, where you got it from?
It's okay, ah
Jelly bean
Daddy and I had a last-minute business trip
So Rose is gonna stay with you for a few days no I don't want you to go she didn't hesitate
You will return home at once or he will face the council and inform them of your crimes
He drew on me
Concentrate
I
Can see what kind of training is this like Ashburn
You'll be hearing from us from the Easter teacher : then just call his shield
Who the hell are you?
Nick Fury director of shield
If I told you we were putting a team together who's, we?
Buddy we're adjourned where's Arthur today you've been at the light
Major girl you CEO
oh
You're giving away all your stuff you let your friend
Fly away with your suit now if I didn't know better you don't know better I didn't give it to him he took
What is power doctor if we can figure out how to tap it maybe unlimited now I
Don't care what time it is this one's weighted line
Whatever was inside him he passed it in to me
There is to court death
See
Hi I'm so sorry but before I hope I didn't hurt you 47 known alien objects at the ground after the portal closed above Manhattan
Please I'm begging you let me die
If he died please
I'm the only authority you will need I point you shoot
It's your staff fighting where they put the warrior interstate in control
There's a fantastic stage one place around the corner you like Chinese
Come on
I didn't do it for him there, he was?
Have abilities he has security clearance he's an agent of shield
The only matter I did not take seriously fully
you know
politics for me
Demeanors that have a powdered child
and apparently
You alienated my favorite daughter through
These couriers can use this tone down the entire civilizations like wheat in a field
My tried so hard to find the form suited you
Capable of displaying the guardians of the galaxy you think I should call him
Madam
Ventures fine I'll do it myself
Hungry
You have a gift mr. Cowell see around red
a
Sec just want to talk to her no
Hypocrite
Just bury me in the ocean
Well my ancestors that jump from ships
Because they know death was better than bondage let them drive
Real ones not bloggers when you're ready let you try that on
I'm sorry to say you're not him
Anybody wanna leave no the time
Kid that's the wizard get on it
Told me yourself not to screw around
This is gonna work Steve I know it is cuz I don't know what I'm gonna do if it doesn't
Hi I'm Eric Boston thank you for watching our updated timeline for 2018 of the Marvel Cinematic Universe now obviously some of this might not
be totally
exact the exact dates of all the Netflix Marvel series aren't totally clear and all kinds of crazy stuff is happening on agents of shield
And then there was all that awkwardness with spider-man homecoming eight years later
Exactly but overall I think we can admit how impressive Marvel Studios
is when it comes to nailing down the timeline of everything and making it all fit and one
interconnected as cinematic universe and for more interesting takes on your favorite Marvel film subscribe to this channel new rock stars and make sure to
follow us on Twitter and Instagram at new rock stars and me Erik Voss at EA boss on Twitter and instead again thanks for watching
and I got a lot of yarn and postcards they got a take down